este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
surf shark vpn luego os doy más detalles
pero antes vamos con nuestra historia de
hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
todo es posible en este año 2020 50 años
más tarde de la guerra de vietnam
el ejército estadounidense vuelve a este
país pero en lugar de ir a atacar a los
comunistas vietnamitas esta vez se van a
defender los no me creéis pues atentos
[Música]
el ssc o vor roosevelt llega a vietnam
convirtiéndose en el segundo
portaaviones de eeuu en visitar vietnam
desde los años 70 la república
socialista de vietnam es uno de los
pocos países oficialmente comunistas que
quedan en el mundo incluso su bandera es
roja con una estrella de cinco puntas en
el medio y a su lado tienen a la
república popular de china que también
está gobernado por el partido único en
este caso el partido comunista de china
dicho de otra forma ambos países tienen
sistemas políticos muy parecidos es más
también a ambos países empezarán a
aplicar reformas de libre mercado en los
años 80 ambos países se han convertido
en las fábricas del mundo y ambos países
comparten fronteras
con tantísimas cosas en común seguro que
pensaréis que china y vietnam son algo
así como el puente infantino y el robert
rodríguez de los países primos hermanos
verdad pues mis queridos amigos de
visual política nada más lejos de la
realidad
mientras bien nada me adopta una postura
más asertiva en el mar del sur de china
beijing intenta controlar la tensión
para que os hagáis una idea solo en los
últimos cinco años sin invitan se han
lanzado varios ciberataques el último
fue hace unos pocos meses cuando unos
hackers vietnamitas robaron datos sobre
el cómic 19 al gobierno chino por su
parte china ha llegado a hundir barcos
pesqueros vietnamitas
y diréis pero y por qué se llevan tan
mal la principal razón es el control de
unas islas diminutas en el mar de china
meridional tal cual como lo oyes al
final de este vídeo entenderéis por qué
esas islas tan diminutas son también tan
importantes y diréis pues menudo
conflicto más desigual verdad cierto
vietnam es un país relativamente grande
con más de 96 millones de habitantes que
lleva 10 años creciendo un ritmo medio
de casi un 7 por ciento sin embargo
estos números palidecen ante los de jim
por hacer una comparación la marina
china tiene 59 submarinos y 59 fragatas
la marina de vietnam tiene 8 submarinos
y 4 fragatas así que cuál es la gran
potencia que podría apoyar a vietnam
pues nada más y nada menos que el tío
sam así que la pregunta que hoy nos
hacemos es por qué
vietnam y china se llevan tan mal que
está pasando exactamente en el mar de
china meridional y cómo es posible que
eeuu que llegó a ser el peor enemigo de
vietnam se esté convirtiendo en su mejor
aliado hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a hablar de
internet y viajes a china ya sabéis que
hay un montón de páginas que no vais a
poder visitar incluidas facebook google
y esta misma youtube y algo parecido
pasa en vietnam aunque en este país sí
que está permitido youtube hay muchos
vídeos que están censurados por el
gobierno probablemente este sea uno de
ellos sin embargo hay una solución que
permite que podáis navegar por internet
libremente y con seguridad desde
cualquier lugar del mundo esa solución
es utilizar una vpn como surf shark
[Música]
de usar que su nuevo ep n fantástica por
muchas razones seguro que todos habéis
caído alguna vez en una de esas webs de
spam que intentan destapar os con popups
a este tipo de prácticas se les llama
phishing
pues bien sûr shark tiene una
herramienta que se llama clean web que
bloquea todos estos popup si todos esos
enlaces que pueden ser un auténtico
peligro pero no sólo es con una única
cuenta de surf shark podéis registrar
todos los dispositivos que queráis el
móvil la tablet el portátil no hay
ningún límite de dispositivos
y siempre tenemos una oferta muy
especial para todos vosotros que seguís
visual política básicamente si utilizáis
el código político terminado en acá
tendréis un 83% de descuento más tres
meses extra totalmente gratis es más
podéis probar su shark durante los
primeros 30 días sin ningún compromiso
en la descripción
os dejo los enlaces y dicho todo esto
ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
camaradas de conveniencia en el año 1954
vietnam se independizó de francia hasta
entonces tanto vietnam como laos y
camboya formaban parte de lo que se
conocía como la indochina francesa tras
la guerra de indochina vietnam quedó
dividido en dos mitades el norte
comunista y el sur que era aliado de
eeuu al igual que pasó en la península
de corea en este caso se use una línea
divisoria totalmente arbitraria en este
caso fue el paralelo 17 como os podéis
imaginar los comunistas del norte
liderados por henning contaban con el
apoyo de la china de mao a fin de
cuentas ambos eran camaradas
revolucionarios y lo mismo ocurrió
durante la guerra de vietnam la que
todos conocemos es a donde el norte y el
sur de vietnam lucharon por el control
total del país durante la friolera de 20
años
[Música]
no lo sabéis eeuu apoyo al sur y china
apoyo al norte sin miramientos para que
os hagáis una idea durante toda la
guerra china envió a los comunistas de
vietnam 560 tanques 164 aviones de
combate y un millón 922 mil pistolas
pero nada de esto os va a sorprender
verdad en principio es lógico que un
país comunista como la república popular
china apoyará al vietcong y lo lógico
sería pensar que tras la victoria del
comunismo en vietnam china se
convertiría en un aliado de este país a
fin de cuentas eran hermanos de
ideología pues nada de eso lo que podría
haber sido una alianza inquebrantable un
romance geopolítico se truncó por culpa
de este señor mejor matar a un inocente
por error que dejar a un enemigo por
error pol pot dictador camboyano este
señor que habéis de ver en pantalla es
pulpo el mayor genocida de la historia
al menos en términos relativos a la
población de su país que era camboya y
no creéis que exagero en absoluto es más
para hablar de él tengo aquí a todo un
divulgador de historia al que seguro que
muchos ya conocéis nada más y nada menos
que miguel de lis hola fonseca y hola a
todos los seguidores de visual político
efectivamente paul potts estableció en
1976 en camboya una dictadura comunista
la dictadura que se conoce como la de
los jemeres rojos
los jemeres rojos creían que la única
manera de acabar con el capitalismo era
eliminando las instituciones previas y a
su vez toda la gente que trabajaba en
ellas de esta manera podrían crear una
sociedad colectivista desde cero era
básicamente resetear el país formatear
lo empezar desde cero por ejemplo los
maestros de escuela fueron acusados de
intelectuales como si eso fuese malo y
de preservar los valores previos a esa
sociedad valores que ellos consideraban
muy individualistas así que fueron
ejecutados y ojo que esto no acabó solo
en los profesores también ejecutaron
abogados artistas gente enferma mujeres
infértiles todas aquellas personas que
en la visión de paul potts no tenían
cabida en esa sociedad
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y así sumando ejecución tras ejecución
llegaron a matar al 25% de la población
de camboya esto es lo que se conoce como
el genocidio camboyano y fonseca y yo si
queréis profundizar más en este tema
hemos estado trabajando en un vídeo en
mi canal donde explicamos este episodio
histórico gracias a la canción holidays
in cambodia de los dead kennedys luego
lo vemos pero antes vamos a volver con
nuestra historia porque como os podéis
imaginar china también apoyó a los
jemeres rojos de camboya y en un primer
momento los jemeres rojos también
apoyaron albert on hermanos comunistas
luchando juntos contra los opresores de
occidente sin embargo si pensabais que
compartir ideología es suficiente para
llevarse bien os equivocáis en el
momento en el que eeuu se marchó de la
zona paul potts empezó a desconfiar de
los vietnamitas los crímenes rojos que
vieron a camboya comunista pero a su
manera no querían que vietnam que es un
país mucho más grande se metiera en sus
asuntos por pod empezó por purgar a
todos los jemeres rojos que se habían
entrenado en vietnam y para un hombre
tan
ejecutar a miles de compañeros de
partido no suponía ningún problema
[Música]
después los jemeres camboyanos se
enzarzaron en un montón de escaramuzas
en la frontera con vietnam
[Música]
así que qué creéis que hizo vietnam pues
en el año 1978 vietnam invadió camboya y
echó a paul potts y los jemeres rojos y
aquí es donde tenemos que hacer un
pequeño paréntesis para explicar el
juego de alianzas que estaba vigente en
ese momento vietnam por un lado era
aliado de la unión soviética y por el
otro lado tenemos a china que se estaba
alejando de las ideas del kremlin para
mantener su soberanía y poder tomar sus
propias decisiones políticas una de
éstas por ejemplo era volver a
establecer relaciones diplomáticas con
eeuu y además por su parte también eran
aliados de camboya
[Música]
en otras palabras que china no podía
permitir que vietnam invadiera camboya
porque eran sus aliados así que en el
año 1979 china empezó una guerra con
pierna habéis oído bien desde 1954 hasta
1979 vietnam no dejó de estar en guerra
en ningún momento primero contra los
franceses después contra los
estadounidenses luego contra camboya y
finalmente contra china y aquí como
curiosidad os diré ya que podemos
aprender mucha historia con canciones y
con música que hay una canción de
siniestro total publicada en 1982 que se
llama fuera las manos chinas del vietnam
socialista y es que esta canción estaba
compuesta por germán coppini militante
del partido comunista de españa que
entonces era afín a las ideas de la
unión soviética es decir ellos eran
comunistas pero no estaban de acuerdo
con las ideas maoístas de china es en
estos años además cuando empieza a ver
una brecha ideológica entre el marxismo
leninismo y por otra parte el maoísmo de
chino
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para que os hagáis una idea la guerra
chino vietnamita dejó más de 60.000
muertos en ambos lados y tanto china
como eeuu pusieron toda clase de
sanciones comerciales a vietnam mientras
tanto vietnam seguía invadiendo camboya
en el año 1986 cada ministro camboyano
tenía a su lado a un asesor vietnamita y
la tercera parte del gasto militar de
vietnam se iba a mantener la ocupación
de camboya en otras palabras que si
pensabais que sólo los países europeos
han creado colonias os equivocáis y si
es cierto el ejército de vietnam depuso
al mayor genocida de la historia el
mayor genocida de nuevo en términos
relativos a la población de su país pero
tampoco penséis que los vietnamitas
trajeron consigo la libertad y la
democracia es más hasta mediados de los
años 80 el gobierno de vietnam seguía el
marxismo de mí mismo hasta sus últimas
consecuencias
la economía estaba hundida
[Música]
sin embargo las cosas cambiaron en 1986
ese año las fracciones más moderadas del
comunismo vietnamita se hicieron con el
poder así es como comenzó el dow y moi
del que ya os hemos hablado en otros
vídeos de visual política básicamente el
doi muy fue un programa de reformas de
libre mercado parecido al que se estaba
aplicando también en chino
[Música]
liberalizar su economía vietnam se
centró en mejorar sus relaciones con el
resto del mundo todo eso explica que en
el año 1989 vietnam se retirase de
camboya poco a poco las relaciones con
china fueron mejorando tanto en beijing
como en hanoi se centraron en crecer
económicamente y comercial así siguieron
durante décadas hasta hacer cosas como
esta
la autopista transfronteriza que conecta
china y vietnam concluye su primer
trayecto de prueba esta noticia es del
año 2018
hablamos de una autopista que conecta
hanoi la capital de vietnam con un mito
que es una ciudad china en su día esta
autopista era todo un símbolo de
reconciliación por fin estos dos países
llamados a entenderse se unían con una
misma carretera y diréis pues bien
problema resuelto dónde está el
conflicto ahora pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
las islas de la discordia atentos de
este mapa porque aquí podemos ver el mar
de china meridional
[Música]
visto desde lejos parece claro donde
llegan las aguas territoriales de cada
país el resto se considerarían aguas
internacionales verdad
error craso error si hacemos zoom
encontramos un montón de isletas
minúsculas que parece como si dios
hubiera estornudado en el mapa pues bien
esas islas son las islas de spratly y
paracelso
en realidad ni siquiera podríamos
llamarlo islas son más bien atolones de
coral es decir un atolón es una
formación terrestre de en forma de
anillo creada por corales si os fijáis
bien en las fotos de estos 130 atolones
de coral que forman las islas paracelso
bueno apenas tienen superficie terrestre
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea el
territorio terrestre de estas islas sólo
suma 775 kilómetros cuadrados que no es
nada y además el punto más alto de las
islas está a 14 metros de altura es
decir que probablemente en el país donde
vivas haya árboles más altos
[Música]
además muchas de estas islas o atolones
no podríamos ni siquiera caminar por
encima pero es tierra firme técnicamente
es territorio terrestre y por lo tanto
susceptible de ser reclamado por un país
en 1932 se consideraba que eran de china
posteriormente de francia y después
fueron invadidos por japón y ahora
existe esta disputa entre china y todos
los países colindantes y ya se lo que se
estaría preguntando pero a quién le
importan unos atolones decorados quien
se va a pelear por algo así pues lo
cierto es que importan y mucho
[Música]
en primer lugar ya se sabe que en esa
zona hay yacimientos de gas y petróleo
es decir que si estos atolones forman
parte de un territorio de un país ese
país podría explotar el petróleo que hay
alrededor sin ningún problema a fin de
cuentas son aguas territoriales pero no
sólo hablamos de petróleo pensando bien
estas islas son el lugar perfecto para
colocar bases militares si china se
hiciera con las islas paracelso podría
tener puertos militares con los que
controlar todo el comercio de la zona y
no hablamos de una zona cualquiera el
sudeste asiático concentra la tercera
parte del comercio internacional es una
de las zonas más pujantes del mundo
todos esos barcos con air pods de apple
móviles samsung y otros tantos productos
made in vietnam tienen que pasar por ahí
pero si china tuviera una hilera de
bases militares a las puertas de vietnam
podría bloquear todas las exportaciones
en un abrir y cerrar de ojos
[Música]
por supuesto que vietnam ha sacado leyes
que dicen que esas islas son suyas y
china ha hecho lo mismo y como ningún
país reconoce las leyes del otro lo
importante en estos son los hechos y por
esos hechos y noticias como estas son
tan importantes
en china va a construir una escuela en
las disputadas islas paracelso
china muestra sus aviones de combate en
el mar de la china meridional
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando cómo
han podido construir todas estas cosas
no habíamos dicho que son unos atolones
donde incluso difícilmente podríamos
caminar por encima bueno pues es que
literalmente han estado construyendo
islas artificiales por hacer de estos
atolones el arrecife que ercros si veis
las fotos ha estado siendo rellenado con
arena y tierra que han estado trayendo
barcos chinos con el tiempo
[Música]
es decir que en pocos años atolones que
antes era poca cosa ahora mismo son
islas capaces incluso de albergar silos
de misiles según muchos analistas es
casi imposible que china pudiera
construir grandes bases militares en
esta zona la poca superficie y el clima
hace prácticamente imposible instalar
grandes sistemas de misiles o puertos
pero en vietnam están realmente
asustados
[Música]
protestas antichinas como os podéis
imaginar estas protestas no son
espontáneas están apoyados por el propio
gobierno de vietnam pero no creáis que
esto es solo un juego político
[Música]
xi jinping y su homólogo vietnamita el
señor nguyen phu trong no se llevan del
todo bien por cierto es llamativo la
cantidad de políticos y personalidades
vietnamitas que se llaman nguyen es el
nombre más común en este país y cuando
digo más común quiero decir que más del
40% de la población tiene el nombre
nguyen pero también son muchos los
pescadores vietnamitas que han sufrido
ataques de barcos chinos es más en este
año 2020 china llegó a hundir un barco
pesquero por las islas paracelso y no
sólo hablamos de escaramuzas los hackers
chinos también han atacado los sistemas
informáticos de gobierno de vietnam y
con la crisis del coronavirus los
hackers vietnamitas hicieron lo mismo
pero esta vez con china en este caso
querían conseguir datos sobre la
pandemia del gobierno de beijing pero
como os podéis imaginar por muchos
hackers que tenga hanoi no pueden hacer
frente a los hackers de beijing y por
eso vietnam también está llevando el
conflicto por métodos un tanto más
civilizados atentos
[Música]
amenaza china con un litigio por el mar
de china meridional creo que os podéis
imaginar lo que estarán pensando en
china cuando hayan leído esta noticia
oh dios mío qué miedo vietnam nos ha
denunciado a lo mejor tendríamos que
buscar un abogado tal vez deberíamos
dejar de construir las artificiales no
sea que no sea alguien nos pongo una
multa y aquí es cuando el juego de
alianzas vuelve a cambiar atentos porque
en este momento es cuando entra en
escena
el amigo americano en el año 2000
vietnam y eeuu firmaron un acuerdo
comercial tras décadas de enemistad
estos dos países volvían a tener buenas
relaciones 20 años más tarde apple ya
está fabricando sus airports en fábricas
vietnamitas y miles de estadounidenses
hacen viajes de negocios a ciudades como
hanoi
ho chi minh city todos los años entre
otros este ciudadano estadounidense cuyo
nombre todos conocemos
trap dice que la segunda cumbre
norcoreana con kim jong-un se celebrará
en hanoi el hecho de elegir vietnam como
escenario de esta cumbre no es
casualidad en cuatro años de mandato
donald trump ha visitado vietnam dos
veces y la diáspora vietnamita adora el
señor trump para que os hagáis una idea
en 2016 el peer search centre realizó
una encuesta preguntando en distintos
países por la percepción que tenían los
ciudadanos sobre el capitalismo según
esta encuesta el país más partidario del
capitalismo en todo el planeta es
vietnam según este estudio los
vietnamitas son más pro capitalistas que
los propios estadounidenses pero no sólo
hablamos de ideología aquí también
tenemos hechos
el portaaviones roosevelt visitar a
vietnam y esta semana noticia de julio
de 2020 esta es la segunda vez en dos
años en la que un portaaviones
estadounidense atracar en un puerto
vietnamita y esto es llamativo porque
hasta el año 2018 la última vez que se
vio un portaaviones estadounidense
pasando por la zona fue en los años 70 y
como os podéis imaginar no era una
visita amistosa precisamente las razones
por las que eeuu manda portaaviones a
vietnam es muy clara están apoyando este
país ante la expansión de china
y creo que ninguno de vosotros se va a
sorprender si digo que desde beijing no
se han quedado con los brazos cruzados
este mismo verano el ejército chino ha
realizado ejercicios navales en la zona
pero ojo no os equivoquéis esto no es
simplemente una disputa entre china y
vietnam son muchos los países del
entorno que se están asustando con el
expansionismo de beijing os hablo de la
india de japón o de taiwán sin embargo
vietnam puede ser todo un aliado
estratégico para eeuu primero tiene una
posición perfecta para poder instalar
bases militares con las que controlar la
zona además vietnam es uno de los
grandes beneficiados por la crisis
económica del coronavirus lo han
gestionado de tal manera que casi no les
ha afectado en el momento en el que
hacemos este vídeo tan sólo han sumado
35 fallecidos y mil infectados
y claramente pueden ser un aliado en la
guerra comercial con china pero todo
esto son temas para otros vídeos ahora
la pregunta es para vosotros llegaremos
a ver una guerra abierta entre china y
vietnam creéis que el apoyo de eeuu a
vietnam puede ayudar a que el país
termine teniendo una democracia
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y recordad los chicos de
visual política y yo hemos estado
preparando un vídeo en mi canal sobre el
genocidio camboyano pol pot y 210
kennedys gracias a los cuales podemos
explicar todo ese episodio histórico
espero veros por ahí en serio os
recomiendo a todos que os paséis por el
canal de miguel' de liszt se dedica a
hablar de historia a través de canciones
de rock en su canal podréis descubrir el
significado histórico de temas como
zombie de los cranberries o the trooper
de iron maiden en serio si os gusta la
historia os gusta el rock y el metal no
os lo podéis perder y por supuesto no
olvidéis que aquí en visual politics
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribiros a este canal y darle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo darle a like
y nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto